c'est monsieur jules moch ancien
président du conseil qui soutient le
pont ce pan dont vous voyez la maquette
coûterait environ 300 milliards
d'anciens francs en sa faveur l'air la
rapidité des secours
il aurait 70 mètres de haut pour
permettre le passage des pagodes mais
contre ce pont il y a les tunnels et
monsieur andré basdevant auteurs du
projet du tunnel mixte route et rail
donc même mode de circulation que sur le
pont monsieur andré basdevant nous
explique comment se présenterait son
tueur nous allons aussi vous le voulez
bien regarder sur une maquette qui est à
côté de nous la coupe transversale de ce
tunnel
vous verrez qu'il est très particulier
par son aspect schématique à la partie
inférieure se tient la voie ferroviaire
qui contient 2 2 voies pour les g
électrique à la partie médiane vous avez
deux pistes pour voitures automobiles
séparés par une plateforme où les
voitures en panne pourrait se garer et
on trouverait aussi lé ventilateur d'
aspiration d'air pur et à la partie
supérieure une galerie d'évacuation
dervishi en effet voilà un problème qui
se pose justement cela ventilation crois
que c'est un des premiers problèmes pour
un tunnel dans ce projet il n'ya
véritablement pas de problème ou de
ventilation en raison de la très grande
section qui a été donnée à la galerie
ferroviaire qui sert en même temps
d'arrivée d'air pur
c'est 60 m² assure toute sécurité pour
la circulation routière
puisque on peut affirmer que dans les
périodes de pointe c'est-à-dire 4000
véhicules à l'heure on ne dépassera
jamais une teneur en oxyde de carbone
supérieur à 1,5 pour 10000 c'est à dire
à peu près la teneur de la rue de rivoli
par une belle après midi d'été
les ferry boat qui assure la liaison
entre les deux continents disparaît
tranquille un jour pour laisser la place
aux tunnels ou au pont claude-henri
salaire n'a demandé son avis à monsieur
louis armand membre du groupement
d'étude du tunnel sous la manche
d'un côté on parle du temps de notre
côté on parle du tuner je sais que vos
préférences vont vers itunes alors je
devrai pourquoi ce ne sont pas mes
préférences c'est le choix qu'a fait le
groupement d'étude pour le tunnel sous
la manche
mais après avoir étudié toutes les
solutions de passage de la manche par un
ouvrage fixe nous avons choisi le
présenter au gouvernement le tunnel ou
plus exactement un tunnel équipe est
électriquement et électroniquement pour
passer les autos parce que cette
solution est la moins chère
quoi qu'elle assure tout le trafic qui
peut être envisagée
pendant les trente ou cinquante années à
venir
cette solution est la moins chère parce
que nous pouvons utiliser intensément ce
pas s'auto électronique de façon à
éviter tout encombrement vous savez que
lorsqu'il ya un passage obligé
c'est l'encombrement qui limite le débit
par conséquent un pont est
obligatoirement un ouvrage très
largement dimensionnés et qui ne débite
proportionnellement qui debbie
proportionnellement moins qu'un outil
qui met en ordre les autos pour passer
le passage obligé
[Musique]